nicht mit Weinen es sind nur Zwiebeln
nicht mit Weinen
bin gleich zurück
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
ja okay ich sag's o'zapft ist also ich
persönlich war ja noch nie auf dem
Oktoberfest wurde schon öfter mal
eingeladen aber ich habe mich noch nicht
getraut ehrlich gesagt weil ich nun
nicht weiß ob ich das kulturell
erleben möchte
ich weiß es noch nicht ich glaube schon
also vielleicht nächstes Jahr dieses
Jahr war jetzt leider keine Zeit werden
wir auch gerne mit Freunden hin aber wie
gesagt ich war nur dort dennoch habe ich
mir gedacht mache ich ein Rezept für
euch was so ein bisschen Oktoberfest
Feeling für euch zu Hause zaubern soll
denn ich weiß dass viele auch die gerade
jetzt in der Zeit auch Geburtstag haben
eine Mottoparty mit Oktoberfest gerne
mal feiern oder auch Menschen die jetzt
nicht unbedingt aufs Oktoberfest zum
Oktoberfest reisen können eben trotzdem
mal eine Oktoberfest Party feiern
möchten deshalb ich hatte ja schon mal
ein Brotsalat
panzanella
ja ich glaube das war richtig und jetzt
habe ich mir gedacht machen wir ein
brezelsalat mit allen Dingen die man
eben auf dem Oktoberfest zu bekommt
außer Weißwurst denn wir essen kein
Weißwurst aber wenn ihr möchtet könnt
ihr natürlich auch Weißwurst dazu nehmen
ganz praktisch ist dieser brezelsalat
weil ihr Brezel nehmen könnt die
vielleicht auch so ein bisschen
altbacken sind die von gestern oder
vorgestern sind falls ihr mal zu viele
gekauft habt und die halt am nächsten
Tag nicht mehr so essen wollt jedenfalls
verwende ich jetzt dafür sechs bis
sieben Brezeln etwas Butter und Olivenöl
denn die Brezeln werden jetzt einfach
geschnitten wirklich einfach fein
geschnitten oder Scheiben so wie er
möchtet und dann mit Olivenöl und Butter
vermengt sodass wir sie im Ofen dann
schön rösten können es hat immer auch
eine schöne Resteverwertung was ihr auch
mit so Brezeln machen könnt ist zum
Beispiel Semmelknödel da könnt ihr
einfach brezelknödel machen
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich jemals auf
meinem Kanal Semmelknödel gemacht habe
ehrlich gesagt
falls nein
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier die brezelstücke bei
uns heißt Brezel und die Anna sagt in
Bayern heißt Brezen ja
richtig so ich hoffe ich sage nichts
falsch so dann hast du nämlich Pech Anna
kommt aus Bayern okay da gebe ich jetzt
Olivenöl drauf und Butter und dann wird
das Ganze schön vermengt und im Ofen
geröstet einfach bei Heißluft da
entziehe ich quasi der Brezel noch ein
bisschen die Feuchtigkeit sie wird schön
knusprig und ich kann leckeren Salat
machen und ihr könnt die auch gerne noch
knuspriger backen und habt einfach
Croutons die könnte dann auch immer ganz
gut aufheben
[Musik]
auch noch ein bisschen geht
wisst ihr kein Olivenöl ist halt auch
keine Lösung
das riecht
so gut kommt jetzt auf mein Backblech
vielleicht nehme ich auch zwei Bleche
damit es nicht so übereinander liegt ja
und dann backe ich bei Heißluft
[Musik]
okay i'm sorry vorhin war noch warm
deswegen habe ich Shorts an und
eigentlich so ein kurzes Top aber dann
dachte mir fürs oktoberfläche braucht
dazu passt hat aber dann keine Lust mehr
in meinen Kleiderschrank zu laufen
deswegen habe ich jetzt die Shorts und
Murats Flip Flops an oder Schuhe an die
in der Sonne eingegangen sind die war
nämlich eigentlich zwei Nummern größer
und deswegen sehe ich so aus wie ich
aussehe
[Musik]
während die Brezel jetzt im Ofen sind
werde ich schon mal ein Dressing
zubereiten denn ich habe mir gedacht
dass ich den Salat einfach schön auf
Platten Anrichte ich habe hier auch
schon mal
Salatherzen auf zwei Platten denn das
soll schon so ein Buffet Charakter haben
und das Dressing stelle ich dann eben
dran und das kann man sich dann so
drüber geben dann geht der Salat auch
nicht ein er zerfällt nicht er wird
nicht matschig und vor allem kann man
sich so viel Dressing nehmen wie man
will und eben auch Zutaten die man
möchte ich habe jetzt hier gedacht da
passt perfekt ein süßes Dressing mit
Honig und Senf mit süßem Senf fürs Honig
Senf Dressing nehme ich etwas
Weißweinessig Sonnenblumenöl süßen Senf
etwas Honig Salz Pfeffer und eine
Knoblauchzehe jetzt gibt ihr hier die
Zutaten in eine Rührschüssel
also ich nehme Messbecher und da nehme
ich jetzt zum Beispiel kein Olivenöl
weil Olivenöl hier zu geschmacksintensiv
wäre also da am besten einfach neutrales
Öl Sonnenblumenöl Rapsöl was ihr eben
gerne habt und einfach die Zutaten schön
verrühren
kann man auch gut aufheben auch wenn ihr
mal das ganze zubereitet habt in
größerer Menge einfach im Kühlschrank
packen dann habt ihr immer ein fertiges
Salatdressing
ich habe da auch schon drei Dressing
Rezepte auf meinem Kanal und wenn ihr
sagt ihr wollt noch mal so ein Basic
Video zu Salatdressings machen wir gerne
noch mal welche weil ich finde Salat ist
immer gut und wenn man sich sowas
anfängt der Woche zubereiten kann und
den Kühlschrank gestellt und einfach
jeden Tag was drüber gehst ist echt cool
spart man Zeit
[Musik]
und die Knoblauchzehe
die Knoblauchzehen ich jetzt einfach
ich habe die so ein bisschen zerdrückt
und damit es nicht zu intensiv wird
halbiere ich sie und lege sie einfach
mit rein jetzt mit Salz und Pfeffer
abschmecken
probierlöffel
[Musik]
als für meinen Geschmack noch zu wenig
Salz aber ich lasse es jetzt so ein
dritte Jutta durch
okay
und der Knoblauch ist richtig gut ich
würde den auch so nach zehn Minuten etwa
rausnehmen ansonsten schmeckt echt
extrem nach Knoblauch okay
Brezel sind im Ofen
Schublade ist offen
ich habe schon den Salat das Dressing
und ich zeige euch mal noch was ich
außerdem an Zutaten verwende ich habe
jetzt hier noch ein paar Salatgurken
Tomaten rote Zwiebeln und Radieschen und
weil es wirklich gut passt noch saure
Gewürzgurken als muss sagen
so ein bisschen für die Deko fände ich
es cool wenn man Radieschen blumen
machen da stecht ihr einfach mit einem
Messer immer so kreuzweise ein so kleine
Dreiecke hoch und runter
zack zack am besten mit so einem kleinen
Messer und dann habt ihr zwei Blümchen
ansonsten würde ich sie hobeln ich Hobel
noch ein paar
[Musik]
so scharf warum muss ich jetzt schon
weinen wenn ich Radieschen schneide das
hatte ich noch nie
ich glaube es erfüllt mich einfach mit
so viel Glück dass aus diesem
Radieschen da so zwei Blümchen entstehen
[Musik]
die Brezel sind jetzt auch fertig jetzt
werde ich die Zwiebeln
schälen und in feine Ringe hobeln und
die Tomaten halbieren und die Gürkchen
auch hobeln und die Gewürzgurken glaube
ich auch hobeln
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich aber gleich ich finde
Salat hoch da wollen wir eine Fliege
Salat essen macht Spaß Salat schneiden
auch aber es ist viel Arbeit vorweg aber
dann du hast dann erledigt hat ist alles
gut also
ich habe hier meine Platte ich habe
sogar zwei
und jetzt kann ich hier das Gemüse schön
drauf dekorieren ihr könnt natürlich
auch alles separat anrichten und mischt
sich das zusammen der eine wird
vielleicht keine Zwiebel der andere
keine Tomaten
bei uns gibt's alles
dann finde ich das immer hübsch wenn das
halt auch schön hergerichtet wird
und wie gesagt wenn ihr auch Weißwurst
mögt dann gibt da ruhig auch Weißwurst
mit dazu
[Musik]
Salat fertig
Dressing ist auch fertig ich würde sagen
wir machen noch Obatzter
einfach so dazu einfach weil was lieben
oder da gibt es auch schon Rezept auf
meinem Kanal aber ich mache das jetzt
heute noch mal so so machen wir das ohne
Obatzter Kai Oktoberfest
also dann stelle ich das zur Seite ihr
könnt es auch so immer gerne schon
vorbereiten die Brezel am besten aber
zum Schluss drauf damit sie eben nicht
weich werden oder einfach separat dazu
anrichten dann macht man sie wie
Croutons drauf den Rest Salat den Jubel
ich da gleich noch unter so bisschen
drunter und dann zeige ich euch jetzt
die Zutaten für Obatzter
ja
diese Zwiebeln hier drin
ach diese Zwiebeln so ging es mir auch
bei ellas Einschulung aber da lagen
keine Zwiebeln
ich habe hier ein bisschen Camembert
wenn ihr einen Reifen kann man bei nehmt
dann ist der einfach ein bisschen
würziger riecht aber auch mehr wenn den
jungen kann man bei nehmt ist der ein
bisschen milder wichtig ist nur dass der
frühzeitig aus dem Kühlschrank genommen
wird damit das Zimmer warm ist habe ich
schon mal weinend was moderiert
ich bin Wein und ich bin gerührt weil
ich mich auf Obazda freue jedenfalls
brachte dafür Camembert weiche Butter
bisschen Kümmel ich weiß ja beim letzten
Mal Kreuzkümmel benutzen weil ich keinen
Kümmel mag und Kreuzkümmel mag ich eher
als normalen Kümmel aber heute mal
Kümmel hier ich nehme auch nicht so viel
dann etwas Paprikapulver und Zwiebeln
ich habe schon angefangen Zwiebeln zu
schneiden und deswegen weine ich auch
so jetzt könnt ihr alle wieder mit euren
Tipps kommen gegen das Weinen
Toastbrot im Mund Wasser in Mund Zunge
rausstrecke Taucherbrille
Schwimmbrille nicht atmen nicht reden
ich weiß
jedenfalls Kopfstand
jedenfalls wird jetzt die Zwiebel schön
fein gehackt
und schaut so ein Rezept wenn man das
isst dann muss da jeder mitessen sonst
stinkt das
war schon Aufnahme
ich versuche die ganze Zeit wegzuhalten
aber ich habe ein wasserfesten Mascara
nicht mit Weinen es sind nur Zwiebeln
nicht mit Weinen
ich muss kurz ins Badezimmer
bin gleich zurück
nee ich habe Zwiebel geschnitten und ich
muss die ganze Zeit Weinen mein ganzes
Gesicht versprochen
guck dir das Gesicht an ich bin völlig
verheult
so das ist schon reality
willkommen in Sallys Welt ja Opa nur und
okay unten ist nicht cool okay
oben Oktoberfest unten Sommerparty
gut
ich sag's dir das war jetzt schon
ja
ich habe kurz gedacht ich weinen
wirklich
aber noch ein bisschen
jetzt nehmen Sie den Camembert mir
geht's jetzt wieder gut und zerdrückt
ihn mit der weichen Butter
ich kann nicht anders ich muss
auskratzen
selbst wenn es nur so ein bisschen
Butter ist
und ich zerdrücke das jetzt einfach mit
diesem Teig Zerhacker ansonsten könnt
ihr auch eine Kartoffelpresse nehmen
oder eine Gabel und das Ganze eben zur
drücken
[Musik]
okay wenn der Käse kurze drückt ist
ich habe immer noch so Augen okay wenn
der Käse jetzt gut zerdrückt ist kommen
die Zwiebelwürfelchen dazu
[Musik]
dann könnt ihr hier ein bisschen Kümmel
nehmen und den mit dem Mörser
zerkleinern
also ich kenne ja keinen Menschen der
Kümmel mag vielleicht gehört ihr dazu
dann schreibt es mir gerne in die
Kommentare macht euch bemerkbar aber ich
mag keinen Kümmel ich nehme den jetzt
aber dazu weil er dazu gehört und ich
glaube auch dass viele also was heißt
ich glaube kümmel ist das so ein
Heilmittel tatsächlich ist ja auch gut
gegen Blähungen zum Beispiel gut für
Verdauung und ich glaube gerade dass man
das bei so Rezepten eben mit dazu nimmt
da ist viel Zwiebel drin viel Käse da
kriegt man schnell man Blähbauch und
deswegen macht man da eben Kümmel mit
dazu
nicht weil es schmeckt so noch was gut
tut aber Fenchel Anis Kümmeltee mag ich
das mag ich sogar sehr gerne ich gebe
jetzt hier noch Paprika dazu müsst ihr
nicht aber ich finde dann dadurch hat es
eine schöne Farbe und das wird Pfeffer
und dann kann ich den Obatzter
theoretisch einfach schön anrichten
durchziehen lassen und ich bin fertig
[Musik]
darf ich jetzt erwähnen dass ihr mich
dazu gezwungen habt Anna und Jutta ich
wollte einfach nur Kochen und Backen
einfach nur in meinem Karohemd was ich
natürlich in blau-weiß gewählt habe und
damit schreibt mindestens einmal ein
Dirndl anziehen
und dann Haare vielleicht deswegen mache
ich das
ich habe mir so ein bisschen
strukturspray in die Haare damit sich
das bissle voluminös aufbauschen lässt
weil guck doch mal hier ist nur
geflochten und hier ist schon voluminös
das heißt man kann hier einfach
das so ein bisschen aufzupfen und dann
kriegt auch jemand der so glatte lange
hat wie ich ein bisschen Volumen ins
Haar
und dann hält das
Dirndl fertig
Jutta Jutta die Frau hat Schlappen zum
Dirndl an oh nein nein
das gibt da ganz anderes gegengefühl
dieser Prinz wenn man ihn braucht zum
Schuhe anziehen
happy
dreh dich nochmal
ihr habt mich hier reingezwungen jetzt
bekommt ihr Autos volle Paket
Oktoberfest hier mein Oktoberfest chillt
Jutta kommt
ohne Dirndl hallo
ich habe so so Jeans wo auch sehr wie so
Lederhosen und so eine Bluse
jedenfalls haben wir hier jetzt
Oktoberfest Stimmung obwohl ich noch nie
auf dem Oktoberfest war auch noch nie so
echt aber
das ist für uns Bayern
also das ist unser brezelsalat Obatzter
und ich fühle mich richtig gut ja super
aus
aber wie klein ich bin
ja das ist echt unfair mit den hohen
Schuhen
aber toll richtig toll
ich fühle mich so ein bisschen wie wie
Rose bei Titanic als er dann so tanzen
genau
das probieren oder wissen wir sowieso
dass es schmeckt nur wie ist das Wetter
für schmeckt also wenn ihr daheim wenn
ihr da haben auch ein bisschen
Oktoberfest Feeling Hamburg dann
schmeißt euch in euer schönstes Dirndl
oder in eure Lederhose packt die Brezel
aus mit diesen drei Sachen und der
arbeitster und der Ort vergessen
da würde ich sagen macht der brezensalat
und O-Saft ist bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss ciao
[Musik]